Hey guys, Tim Ferriss here and wanted to talk about note taking,
I have what you might call hypergraphia,
which means I write all the time.
So I have hundreds of notebooks.
So I feel like I'm in a pretty good position to talk about what the hell to do
with lots of notes.
You need a systematic way of filtering the best stuff to the
top of your attention, at least in some fashion.
So I'll show you a few ways that I do that. It's pretty straightforward,
but the key to all of it is multiple passes for almost all types of
note-taking.
And I'll describe a few different types of note-taking that I do regularly.
The key is multiple passes and constantly asking in effect,
what did I think was important or cool that isn't that important or cool,
and then only selecting the absolute and distilling the absolute best.
So let's take a look at something really small, right?
This is the type of notebook that I would put in a pocket, a back pocket.
And this is from an event. It was actually a very good event,
which was a vanity fair event in San Francisco many years ago.
I want to say around 2013, and I'll show you, uh,
one of the exercises that I like to do when I'm feeling overwhelmed or feeling
like I need a reset, which I do certainly around new year's.
And there are certain seasonal times and I like to reflect.
So I made a list and the top is very simple,
craziest things I could do or eliminate or a limb in parenthesis.
So
I wrote this very quickly and, uh,
part of the point of the exercise was to write quickly and come up with all of
the craziest things I could do that might alleviate stress. Now shut down.
Blog was one. The next one, because this is on multiple passes.
Stop all social media schedule for three months. Question Mark, sell all homes,
stop using money, stop eating for 30 days, cut off feet,
turn up. Not to be something I wanted to do so it didn't cut off my feet.
Give away all money,
buy one house with all money live penniless for one year volunteer in a
retirement home. Okay. So the,
the volunteer in retirement home requires a whole lot of explanation,
but I thought that it would be invigorating and karmically.
Wonderful to do that, particularly with, uh,
ideally a dog like my current dog, Molly, nonetheless,
I did not cut off my feet. I did not stop eating for 30 days.
Although I later did multiple 10 day fasts.
The point of this whole list is to come up with lots of crazy ideas.
They can be bad, they should be absurd. They should seem absurd.
And then perhaps out of all those terrible ideas,
you'll find one that will productively stretch your mind enough,
that you find a solution you wouldn't have considered otherwise.
And in this case, stop all social media.
Schedule it out for three months was the one of the entire list and list goes
on that I ended up choosing and it completely changed how I related to using
social media.
And now that is a regular component of taking off-grid time to recharge
and scheduling things in advance, using many different tools,
whether that's buffer Edgar or Zapier, like happier,
not Zapier. I say that for automating,
a lot of this is also very helpful from say Instagram to other platforms.
And so on.
That is one example of note taking and then reviewing.
So the boxing and circling was a second pass.
Say a week later after the event,
then the highlighting was yet another pass.
Say a quarter later,
I don't know the exact timing on this because I did done it quite quickly,
but there is a schedule for reviewing.
So you're not just spewing onto the page and then forgetting it with the
exception of the next thing that I'm going to show you.
So this is the expedient in the pocket brainstorm type of notebook.
And I'll, I'll show you one more. I'm going to cover it up a little bit,
just to protect names. You can see here,
I've got vanity fair event.
I have a couple of names at the top that were interesting to me, uh,
Graydon Walter Isaacson,
who I much later ended up interviewing on the podcast who is a brilliant guy,
incredible writer, and then a bunch of quotes.
So playing the ratings game prevents you from taking risks. That's Ted Sarandos,
Netflix Seinfeld took four years to find an audience.
Madman was turned down 66 times by buyers. I highlighted these,
they made three passes because I felt like these were incredibly inspiring
reminders that overnight successes rarely are overnight successes.
And then the bottom, right? Uh, it is action steps that I've listed.
And I create these boxes in the bottom
right-hand corner. I'm right-handed might be easier on the left for lefties.
I don't know,
but I create a box in the bottom right-hand corner of all these pages so that I
can put yeah. Potential action steps. The other thing,
what I'll do is I will number these pages and a lot of this can't
show you guys. So, uh, but suffice to say,
if you see that you see page 39, it's kind of hard to see,
but I will number the right hand pages. So one, two,
three, four, five, and then I create an index later,
which I probably can't show you either because there's too much top secret
stuff, create an index in the beginning of a notebook,
much like the index that I would use in books and I'm reading so that I
can find highlights later. And you might ask, well,
what about the pages that don't have numbers? That's easy. That's 0.5.
All right. So if the number on the right hand side is say,
page two, flip it over on the back of that page in the index,
it would just be 2.5. So that's how I keep track of something like this.
The next type of writing that I'll describe is morning
pages. And, uh,
I'm not going to show you this page morning pages popularized by Julia Cameron
introduced to me by a fantastic writer and friend Brian Koppelman
of rounders fame.
The Allusionist co-creator of billions really fantastic guy.
Who's given me a lot of feedback on my writing,
helpful feedback on my writing introduced me to morning pages as a
superpower of sorts for many of his high achieving creative friends who
are professional writers, producers, et cetera.
And the purpose of morning pages is not to write down of stuff
that you will then vet 17 times.
The purpose of morning pages is very different.
It as Julia Cameron who wrote the artist's way, Mike put it,
they are acting these pages as spiritual windshield wipers.
So you're taking the anxiety that you might feel the
distraction, your monkey mind,
and trapping it on paper so that you can get on with your day.
And sometimes they're gems that pop out,
but very often it's really taking a nebulous fear or a nebulous discomfort
or fidgetiness whatever it might be and putting it on paper.
First thing in the morning, hence the name of morning pages.
She recommends three longhand pages. And I'll just give you an example.
So this is from July of last year and I'll
put the location and so on. Uh,
and there is a morning pages workbook that I really liked, but I just,
I just did it in a notebook I happen to have. Here's what I said.
I'm worried and anxious about the notebook, the irony, why? Well,
I have four to six weeks, maybe a bit more based on the agreement.
What's the worst that can happen really?
And then I made a bunch of bullets spend the summer working on an end.
I thought I have to push the deadline. Hyphen fine,
cancel the book and return the advance. Fine. I could still put it on the blog.
Next bullet, make it super short and only great stuff.
Meaning only include great stuff. Say it straight, then say it. Great. Yeah,
it means getting the facts down almost like a,
a computer or iPad instruction manual,
and then trying to improve the pros and say it more cleverly,
put it more cleanly later.
Next I'm feeling uncertain about what to do next or first each day.
And then a bunch of bullets. Just get it all in one or fewer places.
So gathering from notebooks, from digital,
from Evernote all into one place or to the main chapters, right?
And intro and conclusion question Mark.
Remember the humor can include ridiculous stories, such as a, B, C, D,
et cetera. You can see, and you can hear,
this is not good writing and it's not intended to be good writing.
It's intended to be brain vomit. And that's the whole point.
So morning pages I found incredibly helpful for stress, right? Duction,
not principally for insight or structured thinking.
It is unstructured
trapping of your neuroses and anxieties in the Amber. That is the reason page.
So those are morning pages and, and last but not least,
we got this guy five minute journal and I will actually read an
example, uh,
because the format is very straightforward and I can show you what it looks
like. This is what the, this is what the format looks like,
and I'll get you a quote, right? So let's find a good quote.
All right. So here we go. So here's the basic format.
You've got the date at the top of the page. You can get a quote sometimes good.
Sometimes not doesn't really matter, but some of them are fantastic.
Then the prompts. So for the am doing this say in the morning,
I'm grateful for one, two, three, what would make today? Great. One, two,
three daily affirmations. I am blank blank then after it is complete,
say before dinner, before bed three amazing things that happened today. One,
two, three. How could I have made today? Better one, two.
Now this might seem simplistic.
It might seem hokey,
but it is first and foremost,
simple and complexity fails. If I've learned anything.
That is certainly one of the things that I've learned and I've used the five
minute journal for years in different capacities. And, uh,
I am trying to find one that I can share with you, but I'll give you,
I'll give you an example. Uh, and there are many, many,
many that I could pull out. All right.
So I'm going to read, and there are some guidelines that I've been given.
And for many of these, I put prompts at the top that I want to remind myself of.
Uh, so one of the prompts that I've used
is state story strategy and their arrows that
pointed these, that is a SureStep borrowed from Tony Robbins,
meaning you want to improve your physical state, your energy level,
your state of arousal.
So to speak by doing a cold plunge, doing some jumping rope, whatever,
before you create your story,
which will be enabling or disabling or somewhere in between.
And before you then create your strategy for achieving a goal or problem
solving.
Because if you're in a depressed state and this is something I've struggled
with, you're going to create a disabling or a victim based story.
And then your strategy is really going to be very narrow.
It's not going to be particularly oblique or useful in an unusual way.
If you have a heightened state and then you can translate that into an enabling
optimistic story, your strategy will be better.
So I wrote that at the top of many of these particular entries,
blank entries before then getting to them in any case.
So first morning back Montreal was the day before this is
in 2017. I'm smiling at a friend of mine from Montreal.
I am grateful for, and again, this might seem cheesy, but for me,
if I use certain types of note-taking for digesting information or
brainstorming, finding insight, that is one type of note taking.
I use morning pages for reducing nebulous, anxiety or worry.
And I use the five minute journal for focus,
improving focus and execution and appreciation, which you'll see.
So I'm grateful for number one, bird song outside, beautiful number two,
fireflies and stars last night. Number three, great stories,
great sauna times two before bed and rain outside to lulled to sleep.
So I will write down any number of things.
What has been a practice for me is choosing simple, basic things.
In other words, you could say my family, my loving family, and that's great,
but that is a big item.
And I have tried to cultivate and
appreciation of the smaller things, which could be this book,
the convenience of this notebook and the quality of the leather.
It could be one of my favorite coffee mugs, which is this yellow coffee mug,
which has made many appearances in my five minute journal. And that trains you,
I think, to notice the little things which ultimately translates to,
uh, of course noticing the big things, but not vice versa. All right.
What would make today? Great. This was in 2017,
create Bob forms. All right.
So Bob later became T O T, which was tools, Titans.
I believe that was Bob would have been,
I think so I think it was,
I think it was two of the times it might've been travel mentors,
but I think it was tools of Titans. If we're looking at the dates,
look at TFS answers, Shep honor, their fruit Gordon.
So this is the second bullet, uh,
also tot spreadsheet. All right. So that's, uh, Amanda Palmer,
w I created,
and my team helped me create different forms and spreadsheets for digesting
the hundreds of hours of audio and transcripts that we have from
the Tim Ferriss show podcast. Right? So create VOB forms,
look at TFS answers.
And then number three was email 20 new people to test the form.
And these would be forms that are either Google forms or roofer forms or
something like that. That's it? What would make today? Great. That is it.
I'm very prone to overestimate what I can do in a day and underestimating what I
can do say in a year and the benefit of the five minute journal with
very little space and very few,
two bulleted options is that you really need to be concise.
You need to be succinct.
And that helps me to overcome some of my lesser tendencies. Uh,
next daily affirmation. I am forever forward am dash,
no hurry, no pause, no hurry.
No pause is an expression that was taught to me by a friend
former, uh, Navy seal,
and also quite common in Buddhist circles
that I became very fond of.
And I think that made it into tools of Titans and maybe into trouble mentors,
uh, daily affirmations. I am alright,
second bullet good at this four times before.
So just reassuring myself that I can actually complete books because whether you
realize it or not,
I find writing extremely difficult and in paying with great
concerns of insufficiency. Every time I tried to write a book,
if that makes anyone feel better in the PM,
review three amazing things that happened today.
I also always try to include at least one thing that is small Molly.
That's my dog healing while walking around a few different retail stores,
very basic Molly used to have a tendency to pull on the leash sometimes still
does. And she healed really well. Great. That's bullet number one, next bullet,
uh, per novel. So Naval Ravikant,
who's a bit of an Oracle and incredibly gifted and very smart investor.
He predicted that crypto was going to drop 30 to 40% and lo and behold,
it did drop 30 to 40% and he called it exactly a number
three, great late night call with a dear friend of mine. That's it?
Three amazing things that happened today. Boom, those are three.
So I guess late night calls probably the night before that's okay.
Sometimes I may catch up and then last but not least,
how could I've made today better?
So this was late June, 2017.
And it's good for me to see this because I need the reminder,
even though I've been quite good at titrating back, number one,
don't use Kito as an excuse to drink 15 liters of coffee.
Uh, that's the ketogenic diet.
And if I'm using a low calorie keto diet to transition into fasting,
sometimes I compensate for that during the very awkward kind of
gray transition period of keto flu to drink copious amounts of coffee,
which always backfires and has negative side effects.
So don't use keto as an excuse to drink 15 liters of coffee.
I wasn't literally drinking 15 liters.
If those on the internet are taking that literally next drink, less coffee,
comma, use caffeine pills if needed. All right.
So coffee is a really interesting substance and has effects on
the ability to conceive pregnancy and so on.
That seems to apply even if it's decaf as an example.
So this was a period when I was very,
very tightly wound on high doses of caffeine and wanted to make an effort to
decrease my coffee consumption.
And when you use the five minute journal consistently,
what I will do then is say every quarter, go back and look for patterns.
And two of the patterns that I noticed were,
what could I do to make tomorrow better?
The two most common answers were drink, less coffee and wake up earlier.
Those were the two.
So I made concerted effort with accountability to do
both of those things. And that is the five minute journal.
So we have brainstorm insight, note-taking review, right?
For answers, problem solving, interesting goals. And so on.
We've got the,
the morning pages which I can do here or in the morning pages workbook for
reducing anxiety or worries, neuroses, whatever it might be.
And then the five minute journal, which is very helpful for both focus,
keeping things simple and appreciation.
So you don't have to do all three of these every day. I certainly don't.
I use them as needed,
but when I do even one of these consistently,
I see a dramatic difference and not just my quality of life,
but focus and ability to execute consistently.
So hopefully that helps at least one ear out there. And thanks for watching.